hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i'm actually
going to do a tutorial on or review on
the screen recording tool i'm using
right now called cam studio
what this does it is it allows you to
record the actual pixels on your screen
as they move
and you can obviously upload youtube
there's a ton of videos on youtube with
people using their screen recorders and
posting videos so i'm here i'm going to
do a review on cam studio
basically it is a free program so it's
going to be very stripped down version
of what you may have seen in camtasia
studio 6.
um it has all the basic features the
pause and you know a little bit of
editing some annotations so i'll go over
the different modes and different
features with you guys first of all this
is what it's going to look like when you
first open it up it's got the full
window you can also use the toggle
button to switch to a compact view and
just these
so i'm going to use this view for now
when you're recording it shows you your
current frame which is basically um your
time elapsed which is about a minute now
uh 32-bit color and the codec you're
using which i'll get into in a minute
the frame rate the frame rate you're
getting for the recording of your video
and the dimensions you're recording in
so when we hit file we can either stop
pause or exit cam studio which we can
also do from here here or here
when we hit region we can either do a
regular region
a fixed region or a full screen so
regular region is a it's not a constant
region it's constantly expanding and
contracting a fixed region if i click on
it is what i'm in now
you can select the width and height
and also i will show you um
the
height that you can record in to uh get
hd quality for youtube videos i showed
you this already
640 by 360 900 by 600 which actually
gets a little uh horizontal bars wasn't
the best 1088 by 612 and 1280 by 720
so right now i'm recording in 640 by 360
and i have auto enabled which means it
follows my mouse wherever i go
and it drags the corners to pan so if
i'm leaving it it'll catch up to my
mouse
because the auto pan speed is not very
high
so
that is region and also full screen it
will just record the full
1680 by 1050 that my my monitor is at
right now
when i go to options there's a whole lot
more options first of all and this is
where you select the video compressor or
codec that you want to use
i'm using a divx codec right now which
uh is available for download and i've
also done a video on
you can configure how this uh codec
actually compresses your videos and how
it looks when the video is done so if i
configure it i'm using a 720 hd profile
right now which is why
the quality is so good when you hit the
that little hd button on the bottom
right hand corner of this video
so i'm going to hit ok uh the quality i
obviously set to 100 in order to enable
hd
um i've let the frame rate auto adjust
so that if something is running in the
background it will concentrate less on
the actual video recording and more on
that application
so that's basically video options for
this window right here
also this the divx 6.8.5 codec which i
will show you i've already showed you
how to get is pretty much the best hd
recording codec for cam studio
second under options is cursor options
where you can choose what your cursor
looks like whether or not you show your
cursor in the first place and if you
want to highlight your cursor with like
a little yellow circle or square or
something
so i don't actually want to do that
next you can record audio from your
microphone from your speakers or not at
all i'm obviously recording from a
microphone right now and you can also
choose your audio options for your
microphone and speakers as well as this
little synchronization just in case the
audio comes before the video
i'm still tweaking a little with that so
pardon me the video seems a little bit
off
next
is enable auto pan which is very
important if you're if you're um
if your cursor is actually moving around
the screen i can disable auto pan and i
can move my cursor out of your screen
right now but that wouldn't be very
helpful because you wouldn't see what i
was doing
so next is auto pan speed which i've set
to 90 which is pretty decent speed which
means it's not like flying all over the
place but it's pretty smooth
as you can see so that's my you can go
from zero to 200 by the way from maximum
pan speed
next under options is program options
where you can minimize the program on
start which means this whole window here
won't be here
there is
high flashing rectangle during recording
which is um just this tiny
little green flashing rectangle and this
right here um which is actually showing
where i'm recording on the screen but no
need for that i'll just leave it
uh save settings on exit definitely do
leave this checked so you never have to
uh reselect your codec and your
resolution and your auto pan speed every
single time you open
capturing capture translucent layered
windows this is good if you're using
windows vista arrow very very good
and also play when it stops temporarily
direct for temporary directory recording
which is just
making sure you don't accidentally exit
your video
recording thread priority i suggest you
leave this at normal otherwise it'll
kind of take away from the cpu usage of
other programs
and troubleshooting
also you can record and preview your swf
file upon completion if you're recording
to swf but i am recording to api format
and also i showed you an entire video
just for the keyboard shortcuts for
starting recording ending recording
showing layouts etc so watch that video
too in hd
last but not least actually not last but
we have screen annotations which allows
you to put a little uh let's say you
want to just have a little um a little
arrow pointing something on your screen
uh i can actually add those into my
video as i'm recording
other tools include visions which is
kind of the same here i'll put a little
actually you can actually see a video of
me on screen because that doesn't work
very well but i'll exit out of that
next you have
uh your view which i showed you you can
change from normal compact and button
view just from this uh this button right
here boom boom and boom so those are the
three views i'm in normal view right now
and last but not least there's a help
button which you know shows you what
version of cam studio you're using
um
that takes you to the cam studio website
for extra help faqs donations etc not
very important to the review but um that
is basically it that is uh what i used
to record my screen so if you're
wondering uh how to get this in hd i
also have a video on how to record in hd
um so go ahead and watch those videos
there's a ton of videos on my channel on
cam studio so watch those and rate
comment and subscribe so if you have any
other video tutorials that you'd like me
to do
um just go ahead and drop me a comment
and i will definitely get back to you go
ahead and subscribe and send me a
message and i'll get back to you and do
a video to the best i can mention your
name in the video so thanks for watching
guys and subscribe peace
you